in the driving rain they kept coming
gathered outside of the gates of
buckingham palace the weather no barrier
to witnessing this moment in history
ever since
we were born she's been our queen so
this is
very big news for us and very sad news
a swirl of rumors had seen small numbers
a mass here earlier in the day and just
before 6 30 confirmation
the enormity of this moment for some a
struggle to take in
to see a flag behind you they're sort of
you know slowly lower and it was just a
sense of
you know both realization but also i
think this united
love and i think it was it was an odd
kind of surreal feeling there yeah it's
a really emotional moment that even if
you're not born british
she represented the best values of the
country that actually made me stay here
i think there's been so many like
generations that have come through and
just known her as this like presence
even without being a political voice
just being this kind of yeah stability
and sort of
yeah more than just a figurehead i think
you know nation's grandmother is
appropriate
outside of windsor castle similar scenes
people wanting to mark this moment she's
been part of my life forever
and
you know she's not here
and you know
you hope but you appreciate that you
know
her age it was expected at some point
but
even when it happens it's still a shock
i'm absolutely shocked i couldn't
believe it and i actually didn't think i
would be upset but i am and i have no
idea why it's just i think she's just so
in everyone's psyche now so i'm not even
a royalist but i'm still really upset
her legacy is so prominent
i mean when i think of britain when i
was growing up it's always been the
queen the royal family
and just like a beacon of stability as
sunset the sea of people building
outside of buckingham palace umbrella's
up a little rain not enough to put
people off being here to mark this
moment
in amongst the crowds here you get a
very real sense of the shock and the
loss many ordinary people who have been
moved to come here are experiencing and
you find people here from all
demographics and all generations
barriers brought in in anticipation of
the crowds to come many more expected
here in the days ahead as the sun sets
on the reign of elizabeth ii
braving the very british weather long
into the evening
fitting for such a somber night katie
spencer sky news